or Fisher random so here we go team
black I started out the last stream with
team black let's go with Sicilian land
Sebastian akov open not open let's try
this how should you be responding to
this one um I don't think you should
respond with castle there I think that I
think the move is actually see three to
try and show that this is a maybe not so
great move okay so what do I do in the
meantime e6 or d6r my candidate moves
I'll go d6 my bishop come out i also
want to stop this advance so i'll get my
night out maybe as soon as possible so
that's another reason let's say to go
with my deep on instead of that my epon
here now i could come out and actually
I'm not threatening to take this pawn
because of Queen check so what does this
really mean what am I getting at here
hmm just get develop actually maybe
there was a reason I was saying you know
I want to develop my night but maybe
there's a reason to actually go with
just the e6 advance let's see what um
let's see what why wants to do here
let's see about that d 4 D for
oh d for I could take on e4 or can I
those are big questions okay iphone a
better not be listening to the stream oh
okay here we go let me just grab that
pond I better take that pond I don't
want to run away my night he doesn't
have a good square okay I'm uh I'm also
three moves behind the developments are
from castling so I better really give
some consideration to this to this right
here this esox move this night is not
protected it's something like Queen
check going to be played I think I just
played b5 and you don't really go too
far Bishop 2d6 Queen c7 maybe I think I
like Bishop 2d6 first what am I going to
do with this guy okay I'm get my bishop
out or is this pin gonna be a pain might
be a pain let me let me just go here
just prevent some nonsense with Bishop
to g5 let's see I want a castle I want
to eventually move my beep on I could
have also um just taken here maybe I
know I'm not going to do that I mean cat
let me castle first why was I so
reluctant to to grab on d4 right there I
did think about it for a second and then
I'm like no I'm just in a castle why did
I do that what it was that last thing
that I thought about before I made my
decision to Castle anybody know which
may be a reason to go with castle
instead of capture okay i'm seeing a
reason why I should have captured but
actually he oh man okay hang on I'm
seeing a reason to maybe I wanted to
castle okay yeah and I'm going to end up
in a força ruski I was I was concerned
about isolated pot or I was concerned
about allowing the night to get to see
three surprisingly I have actually
advantage and I'm looking right at that
because I'm probably gonna have to go
fast to win this one because this is
this is a this is just a pawn plus that
white now asked looking at the the
structure i was i was too fixated on
pawn structure instead of just the
tactics right there potential that white
has so this pond is going to be around
for a good while so what do i do what do
you do well i'm not going to trade
queens i don't think and not so fast
let's see i have to move quick that's
the big plan at this point you better
move quick you better move quick what
happened to my opponents time I thought
they had two minutes I thought something
was funny that with that but I didn't
look at it any further did I put a sworn
it said two minutes a little bit bad
cesky playing tricks on me I can't have
that hi big basing I might be basing
some of my moves off of that clock man i
know it's I know it's done that before
so and I don't think my um i'm being
deceived here let me see my eyes
deceiving me that what's going on I
don't think that that's a good move
let's see why I think I get this pawn
back the other thing is that i'm trying
to take the Queen and then played it and
played ac2 so in other words if I'm if
I'm taking the Queen the bishop would
have to be recapturing i'm also on this
pond now um okay well
I think okay i know i could get the pawn
back might I have been trapped actually
if just 83 was played now I could do
something like night takes that night
here okay so let me can I even it can I
even trust the clock anymore I'm seeing
204 I'm seeing 157 i'm calling it out
right now okay to trade queens or not to
trade queens let's see about that take
your first let's take here first I'm not
afraid should I be afraid I'll take here
if this Queen was able to come out on
this diagonal I would definitely want to
get rid of the Queen's first but that's
not the case my night could still cause
some issues making use of c2 if he's
kicked away of course I just run away
and fortunately comes with an attack on
the bishop I think that that was a clean
pond that white hat all right so let's
just run away that was a clean pond and
it was just a misstep by team whites and
now i'm looking to pick up the bishop
hair this bishop wants to play I promise
he's not doing anything right now but he
really does want to do something and I
don't I don't want to take just yeah I
like my night better than bit better
than the bishop at this moment maybe
I'll take the bishop only after the
Queen has moved if the bishop wants to
save itself okay maybe I'm able to buy
myself time for b6 Bishop here my other
choice is going to be Bishop d7 to c6
and well maybe now I should be taking
this guy
um what am i doing
yeah let me let me just take that I
should have maybe consider bishop here
yeah that would have been better oh well
okay this is going to look scary because
it is scary Bishop here Queen c8 I guess
we are down to the wire we are both in a
bullet mode here can I rook doing
something i'm not sure what I want to do
in my light scrub it oh my bishop might
want to play here not now though wants
to go here to box out the night I need a
flight we both need flight squares I
think that night has to go yeah I can't
allow the night to jump in there and I
think these two pounds will do well to
challenge these three and we're
approaching a potential good versus bad
Bishop ending if i take this bishop then
this is going to be a an issue so okay
the the bishops are off and maybe maybe
i will take if i could get my king on
that square so I have a better King
position what does this really mean it's
open stuff up I'm going to take like
this I would I'll plan the a file i have
this supported and now i have at least
an active rook and I could cut off the
King I don't know if I could really put
it to good use let me ask this record
question first what are you going to do
okay you're going to go there now I want
to make sure this pond doesn't move and
not you get a better King position here
and then here this this King is
constrained and no my King has a better
better position give a check I think the
rookin ends up getting stuck no no it's
just dropping a pond let me give a check
first grab here this pontiff know now
that rook is like close to dead isn't he
yeah now he just can't move the king the
the rook is dead my opponent is flying
now let me just make sure there's no
material for team white okay there's no
time um good game let me back up that
was um I think I'm well I know that I'm
the one that made the first big air
again I was fixated on it was it was a
frame of mind thing just quickly
thinking back to that do I take on d4 or
do I castle that position right there I
was trying to make a point as to why I
thought castling was better and it
failed tactic tactically it's just
something simple is ok I'm just going to
grab a pond and hang on to it ok so I
was saying at this point that I think c3
right now is a good option I looked into
this very very briefly after I play this
on stream the one time and I was
wondering what it is white should maybe
be doing or what they can be doing and I
think it's C 3 and then after a six the
bishop is then able to do a typical Roy
Lopez type of maneuver where it comes to
a 4 and if it's hit organic it could
tuck itself back to see two so that's a
reason to maybe even consider c3 right
now by castling you don't have that
option after a six if you go to a for
you're getting killed in the in a way
that's reminiscent to the Noah's Ark
trap it's only how that seed three at
that moment is something to consider for
white and for me what can I be doing
what can I be doing different here is is
d6 ok i don't i don't see how d6 cannot
be ok maybe bringing my night out wasn't
a good idea maybe maybe e6 is better
actually and that's so sure because that
night seemed to be quite powerful after
you did that pond advance I think we're
actually right here is the first
opportunity
have to just take right away with this
ensuing be4 fork on both my night and
Bishop highlighting the awkward enough
the awkward looking placement right now
of my night on 85 and so the bishop move
just take happened to move later and
there's there's no way that I'm better
here you back up how you should so let
me just go back real quick right here as
soon as you do this move I have to
really consider do capturing on c5 and I
didn't so I should take recapture and
okay i give you the C 3 square but then
I could try and play against your
isolated deep on so we both had some
some issues right there and c4 is just
going to give back that pond I'm pretty
sure 83 I was giving some attention to a
three Queen takes Queen Bishop takes
Knight takes Knight Bishop takes Knight
knight can now make use of c6 with tempo
and maybe you're then able to save this
pond actually maybe by going to d6
although I could take and then get them
back yeah it seems like after you place
for it's me it's a tempting move to 2xu
my central night away but maybe you
could all do something a bit more column
is is be four available or trying to
think here what could be done ready to
get this guy
or maybe maybe take this night first
maybe this is a main difference maybe
take on c6 first and then after c4 if i
go to be 4i think it's lost because of a
three by taking on c6 first I recapture
with the pun then following up with c4
if i go to be 4i can't get back to that
c 6 square so maybe a switch switching
the move order take the night recapture
c4 and then i have to go f6 or c7
probably f6 and then i'm pretty sure you
could hang on to this c 5 pound after
Bishop d6 i think that that would be an
improvement taking out c6 and only then
c4 but as it turns out i'm able to get
that pond back I still don't think that
I'm the better side I have the I have
the two bishops at this point and this
was another thing I should have maybe
just played Bishop here maybe I could
make use of a 7 with my queen after I
take it's a bit uncomfortable to meet a
threat against my queen once you tell
the rook on the D file but okay Bishop
hair and I think we're already down to a
minute at that point and after the smoke
clears there's not really much even even
if it just happens I'm up upon it's very
difficult to convert a 4 verses three of
these work and pawn in games yeah I
wonder if there was a way that you could
have just made made sure that this pond
is dead and then just go and try and
hold a draw because I think I i I'm
ending up certainly with the better rook
in this end game but you know we're both
down on time okay ah good game Andrew
let me close out